und dann habe ich mir dass ich habe mir
das halt bestellt
hallo mein name ist so kann herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video vom normalerweise mache ich mir
vor videos immer gedanken okay was nehme
ich jetzt eigentlich auf wenn ich
irgendwie ein spiel spiel okay was
versuche ich ja irgendwie zu erreichen
was könnte vielleicht interessant sein
für die leute allerdings heute ihr seht
schon gespielt ich habe aber überhaupt
keinen plan was wir machen wollen
vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch an die
letzten teil des films erinnern da haben
wir unter anderem dieses haus gebaut wo
wir das hier auf den boden gemacht haben
wer hat denn dann penis in den garten
gemalt meine damen und herren die person
in dem es sich um das ist luca luka ist
eigentlich schon fertig auf toilette
steht da aber doch immer läuft jetzt
ganz normal rüber zu seinem pc und geht
jetzt in den ich habe wirklich überhaupt
keinen plan was wir heute machen wollen
in dieser folge dass sie jetzt unser
haus wir haben hier vorne unseren tool
ich glaube kennt das alles noch die hier
vorne haben wir noch luca das muss erst
mal aufräumen hier dass schimmel ja
schon qualität verdorben luca kommt hier
vorne angelaufen sieht das essen nimmt
sich ein bisschen in börger setzt sich
schön hin auf die seite denkt an müll
natürlich denkt er an müll das schmeckt
gut
sogar das gefällt mir richtig gut das
würde ich sagen ist jetzt noch nicht
mehr sondern wir wollen das ganze jetzt
mal auf genauso wie das den du auch
aufräumen wird und das wissen von
visionären messerblock und ich nicht im
supermarkt und hab mir gedacht ich
brauche messerblock denen dann aber
nicht gekauft weil ich habe kein geld
mit
warum war ich dann überhaupt im
supermarkt ja das sehe ich ja jetzt was
ist denn das hier unten auch für eine
scheiße
die kaluga du musst hier alles irgendwie
ein bisschen spielen ich glaube luca
will jetzt wie
da seht ihr was ich für vollidioten hier
erzogen haben allerdings meine damen und
herren luca lebt natürlich nicht alleine
in dieser tollen will das wäre natürlich
viel zu groß wenn er irgendwie da allein
leben würde sondern wir haben natürlich
auch eine mitbewohnerin und zwar ist
dass er die hier die je grad pennt luca
wird jetzt mal zu der dame hier vorne
hin gehen ich denke wir wissen doch alle
dass das sie natürlich baby ist die
haben wir in einem der letzten sims
videos mal kreiert luca denkt natürlich
wieder nur an den laptop allerdings
meinten sehr sehr viele leute in den
kommentaren zu mir
luca du spielst ja sims komplett falsch
dass er nur je titel geld oder was ist
das da vorne vom typ vor allem warum
läuft dieser typ hier einfach nackt lang
würde sagen wir halt mal ganz kurz die
zeit an und begutachten diese person mal
eben er läuft sehr ja gerade foxi dpa
red fox was haben sich die eltern mit
dem namen gedacht wahrscheinlich sind
deine eltern nicht zufrieden
nun entsteht dass luca eine sms bekommen
von nancy dass die mit ihm abhängen
möchte aber wir kriegen jetzt mal ganz
kurz eben auf diese bianca heinecke hier
vorne machen mal dass sie nicht
irgendwie ihren kuchen da ist sondern
sie soll jetzt mal hier vorne zu ihm und
sich mal lustig vorstellen hallo ich bin
foxi ich finde es mega schön dich hier
kennenzulernen ich gehe sehr gern ins
museum würde da auch sehr gern mit dem
atrix natürlich erst mal ein schritt
zurück ja ich habe einen mitbewohner an
der macht wort vielen müll muss ich halt
den ganzen tag immer aufräumen vilbel
überall nur da weiß ich nicht mehr was
ich da überhaupt noch soll weißt du weil
das bin halt nicht ich war genau das
bist du ja das bin ich das bin ich ja
das was du kannst autos mag ich gern da
fahre ich gerne ferraris wenn nur ein
hass
darum haben wir uns erstmal die beiden
hier sind jetzt also irgendwie in ihrem
lovefilm
oder in ihrem psycho film die beiden
können auf jeden fall gleich noch weiter
reden etwa ist das nicht nancy hier
vorne dafür dass es dass es ist das ist
das bin ich jetzt total nancy blue
hustler luca der sms geschrieben also
luca würde ich sagen der hört jetzt mal
auf mit den laptop sachen darum geht mal
zu nancy und ihr könnt ja ich habe mal
ein bisschen den tag verschönern
das heißt luca geht jetzt mal hierzu
nennt sich in die warteten natürlich
wird auf nancy du musst auf luca warten
der luca di luca du musst durch sie
nennt sie läuft die beiden haben sich
gefunden meine damen und herren küssten
sich natürlich erstmal was will der typ
denn herr luca das war's jetzt mit nancy
oder was er kommt jetzt der bitten baby
zu stimmt nancy ist ja schwanger von
luca das hatte ich ja gar nicht mehr
offen schirmen freunde was geht denn
jetzt hier überhaupt abkommen luca jetzt
lauf doch nicht vorweg man das ist eine
verdammte frau nancy betont durch ihre
gangart auch gar nicht dass sie
schwanger ist das ist mir übel und
entspannen zwischen den beiden daheim
ich würde sagen wir jeden fall wieder
zurück zu mir wie hast du foxi dafür
fucking fucks in volk direkt hier in
unserem pool eingeladen wie die kann
wikando kann der deutsche wieder hier
sein freunde was geht ab ich komme
überhaupt nicht klar was hier gerade
passiert die wir jetzt hier vorne beim
barbecue und kocht irgendwie was aber
ich würde sagen wie wir versuchen sich
doch hier so ein bisschen mit den foxi
zu verkuppeln deswegen will ich sagen
machen wir über probleme beschweren das
ist immer ein mega gutes thema beim
ersten date ein paar sekunden später
irgendwie kommt der glaube ich nicht aus
dem pool raus
[Applaus]
nach vier stunden schwimmen hat es da
mal hin gekriegt foxi rock shox kummer
so sehe ich gerade aus falls mich siehst
habe ich sie jetzt hier schon mal gesagt
hier nochmal so sehe ich aus biete ja
das habe ich schon in büchern gelesen
dass du aussiehst tschüssi schöne
unterhaltung war das mit dir
simons vielleicht ja immer wieder
irgendwann ich habe immer noch meinen
berger mit besitztümern prahlen
richtige be here ich hab mir letztens
ein paar alpakas rumlaufen sind ja ja
sie sind die oft ja die da lang das
nachts megaspaß ja ja ja und ich liebe
einer kaste baby wo gehst du warst wie
mache macht jetzt sport oder warum hat
die hier irgendwie ihre sportsachen ein
baby wo läufst du läufst du nicht dass
das ist so alt wie das ist doch
[Musik]
wb der ist der ist abgelaufen
denn da ist auch kein gemüse drin
jan immer ruhig noch ein bisschen du den
habe ich in der letzten folge des teams
gemacht das ist ein paar monate her
na ja da ist selbst das wasser pinkl
schimmelt ich weiß nicht was die bi hier
soll aber die bi könnte eventuell
nochmal mit dem luca unterhalten
allerdings ist der luca glaub ich gerade
außer haus und wen haben wir denn hier
sonst noch so irgendwo eine
nachbarschaft habe ich irgendwelche
leute davor einen kleinen jungen liebe
ist jetzt hier bei dem kleinen jungen
angekommen mal schauen aber was die sich
jetzt unterhalten so sehe ich aus der
zeit ziemlich noch nicht gesehen hast
sage ich sie hier noch mal ich hab ne
brille
ich hab dich schon mal gesehen im
schulbus wir sind hier zur schule
gefahren daher haben wir ganz viele
vögel auch so wie wir zuhause
da fliegen gibt es da nicht da kann man
hilfen aus der schule fliegen wenn man
schreibt ja ja ich hatte letztens on ice
das war lecker und dann habe ich mir
dass ich hab mir das halt bestellt ja
soll ich den leasing ist kann es nicht
vielleicht beruhigen oder nächste mal
mit meinem auto herumfahren ich fahren
ferrari
ich war jetzt mal liegestütz kam am 1
ich gehe mal zu meinem ferrari dann
jesse ich bin so sportlicher magath
freuen ich entschuldige mich für dieses
video essay wer hat sie denn in der
zwischenzeit ist red fox fox kopf wieder
in unserer wohnung angekommen und gehen
dort sache computer hallo herr ist
jemand auf meinen youtube-kanal dran
also ich würde sagen die bibi kreutz
stehen jetzt erstmal hier darauf an was
passt sich jeder darauf überhaupt
einbildet was ist denn überhaupt los
foxi j fox mox sollen die bibi wird sich
jetzt mal mit dem j fox hier unterhalten
was
sollte es trotz fox fox fragen was der
an unserem computer immer macht der ist
sie auf klo alter was fällt dir ein
lukas gerade wieder zu hause angekommen
und geht natürlich erst mal schwimmen um
sich mit seiner mitbewohnerin baby hier
zu unterhalten baby ich hatte richtig
stinkende füße hier über die risiken
kann ich mir leider nicht leisten und
dann habe ich gedacht ich muss sein aber
warum muss ich dann doch nicht hin weil
jetzt bin ich ja schwimmen jessie j
ich habe für viele freunde aber die
bibel ist natürlich nicht locker sie
möchte sich natürlich mit luca
unterhalten und interessiert sich für
sein leben wenn ich dich sehe muss ich
an müll denken
gestern kam ihr ein kino an und der ball
lag so krass dann kam die polizei und
die mitgenommen weil der hat ja böse
sachen gemacht und dann kam noch immer
mehr polizeibeamte dann und dann unter
das war's ich geschlafen was macht den
bbi jetzt schon wieder also wir schauen
man sie steht hier vorne und denkt an
stinkende füße und wie du kannst du
jetzt eigentlich schon mal aufräumen
luca kommt jetzt vorne und ich möchte
lukas sie jetzt beim baby davon
überzeugt dass sie hier noch ein
bisschen weiter aufräumen muss also was
unterhalten sich die beiden hier vorne
da draußen eine fledermaus sie war so
groß wie eine fledermaus zu helfen und
dann habe ich meinen elektro roboter
genommen und wollte die kaputt machen
und jetzt nur auf den punkt zu kommen
das war es jetzt nämlich und jetzt räume
auf verdammte scheiße
von daher will ich an dieser stelle
jetzt auch das heutige video band meine
damen und herren ich hatte einfach mal
wieder bock ist sims zu starten und habe
mir gedacht okay ich unterhalte mich
einfach mal mit ein paar leuten und
gucken ob es den charakteren gut geht
und ob das essen wirklich schon seit
monaten vergammelt darum steht wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann das gerne mal ein
leichter wenn ihr mehr sims haben wollt
dann schreib doch mal gerne die
kommentare was ich erwarte in der
nächsten folge machen sollen solche
eventuell noch eine andere person
einziehen lassen oder soll ich einen job
suchen oder was soll ich in der nächsten
folge sims tun wo jetzt meine damen oder
etwas mit dem ihr glaube ich nicht
gerechnet hätte uns war das auto das
erste teil vom laz videowänden ziemlich
vorbei ist das wasser ziehen
das war's jetzt ihr vom video hier
können
jetzt hier bei den kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten meinen job aus schenkungen
jetzt findet ihr zwei andere videos und
wenn ihr sohn abonnent zeit könnt ihr
auf die glocke klicken dann willkommen
die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]